so this is Asha and he's one of the Kobe
19 detective dogs a sure the spaniel has
350 million sensory receptors in his
nose the government is paying half a
million pounds to see if he and five
other sniffer dogs can be trained to
sniff out people with kovat 19 dogs will
be screening individuals up to 250
people an hour now this is a point five
of a second sniff and they will be
reliably able to tell whether somebody's
carrying the virus and therefore needs
to take a medical test to be isolated
this is how the same dogs were trained
to detect people with malaria odor
collected from patients clothing is
placed in one of eight containers the
dog gets a treat if it can find it and
sit down a kovat 19 training the samples
will come from people who have the virus
but no symptoms and if the training
works the dogs could screen 250 people
an hour as they arrive at UK airports
well I think it's really important to
think about this cleared 19 is the
problem that's not going to go away and
be with us for a year or two so in order
to prevent infections sparking off into
this country
we need to have good border security to
identify people coming in with with the
virus and if our dogs can do can pick up
people I think that would be a very
strong thing to do the researchers say
they'll know if dogs can be trained to
detect people with coronavirus by
September in which case hundreds could
be working in UK airports by the end of
the year Jared sub Sky News